but we are going to begin with the news
and the news this morning as a key piece
of evidence in the federal government's
classified documents case against former
president Donald Trump you heard about
it now you're hearing it an audio
recording that's been obtained by CBS
News and in it you can hear the former
president discussing what he and his own
voice calls secret documents at his golf
club in Bedminster New Jersey the
recording was first revealed by CNN and
our senior investigative correspondent
Catherine Herridge is in Washington she
got hold of the tape just last evening
Catherine good morning to you a lot to
listen to here Good morning Tony in the
two-minute audio recording the former
president announced his former top
military adviser General Mark milley and
appears to share what he describes as
highly confidential and secret
information involving a defense
department plan of attack on Iran and in
the indictment he's accused of showing
the records to a small group apparently
with no security clearance
they said he wanted to attack Iran and
what
is
given to me
a newly obtained audio recording may be
a key piece of evidence in special
counsel Jack Smith's case that alleges
former president Trump put National
Security at risk by mishandling
classified documents including one he
suggested was prepared by joint Chief's
chair General mark milley
[Music]
this was him they presented me this just
off the Record but they presented me
this
Tim
Department according to the indictment
the recording from 2021 captured a
conversation Trump had at his New Jersey
golf club with a book writer a publisher
and two staffers none of whom are
believed to possess a security clearance
yeah I just found isn't that amazing
this totally wins my case you know
except it is like highly confident
there's a secret look at this the audio
recording appears to contradict Trump's
recent claim that there were no
documents and the material was just
newspaper clippings that was a massive
amount of papers and everything else
talking about Iran and other things and
it may have been held up or may not but
that was not a document I didn't have a
document per se there was nothing to
declassify these were newspaper stories
magazine stories and articles Trump has
repeatedly insisted he Declassified all
the documents he took with him but in
the recording yes
this recording shows that Donald Trump
knew that he had a document when he was
no longer president that he could not
declassify Ricky cleeman a CBS News
legal contributor says the audio
recording still leaves the door open for
the defense he's going to say that he
never had a document in his hand up in
Bedminster New Jersey and that he was
just waving around some papers
willy-nilly
former president Trump earlier this
month pleaded not guilty to 37 counts
related to the mishandling of classified
documents he posted last night that the
audio was quote illegally leaked and
spun by special counsel Jack Smith the
FBI and justice department and called
the tape and transcript and exoneration
Tony
doesn't deny the authenticity of it
though that's notable Catherine there's
a court hearing in Florida today
regarding the handling of those
classified documents what can you tell
us about that well that's right Trump's
valet and close Aid is set to be a rain
this morning in Miami Florida while NADA
is accused of being part of a criminal
conspiracy with the former president in
the documents case according to the
indictment not have moved boxes in and
out of storage at Mar-A-Lago illegally
withheld documents and made false
statements to Federal investigators the
justice department wants the trial to
begin in December Tony
see if it does Catherine thank you